[Music]
in buried treasure news submitted by
porch for the soul a man was arrested
trying to dig up treasure thought to be
buried on a Nevada ranch
I wonder what type of branch that is
ranch Oh like the what was it the bunny
ranch yeah chicken ranch or whatever
yeah I actually know someone who found
treasure in California like gold
treasure yeah I know they got like tons
of money - it was crazy get my dream
dude
I have absolutely no idea you want to be
a nerd with the metal detector on the
beach you know just April that's how
they probably find it we don't talk
about just finding a random bag of money
and that's literally finding a random
bag of money I know I'll have to ask
it's like those treasure hunters that
find like sunken ships in Spain that
were supposed to be travel across the
seas yeah and they just find treasure
chests full of [ __ ] money and they
just walk away with eight billion
dollars that sounds like a lot of work
oh it is I mean they've been doing their
whole lives so you guys wouldn't go do
that I would say from the comeback I'm
just scared of the ocean you go out
there some [ __ ] happens and your [ __ ] do
you like the ocean I like the ocean when
I can see the land below or the land
over there I guess see the beach
I got a seal and I gotta see both I
gotta see you over there and I gotta see
it oh yeah the Benicia it scares the
[ __ ] out of me too yeah but I'll still
do it like if I'm in Hawaii I'll jump
off a boat and I'll swim but I still see
the boat so I know there's an anchor
point oh yeah you know yeah what if the
boat leaves you [ __ ] dude
I just don't like the ocean it's like
someone else's home you know what I mean
in sharks or enemies I'm like no super
conceited didn't see a shark just
[ __ ] crying
dramatically [ __ ] with it no just I know
I'm afraid of it I'm in someone else's
home it's someone else's home I wanna be
in it that's what food is good story
here it's begins back in 1998 oh this
man who was one of five children of Las
Vegas Las Vegas casino magnate Benny
Binion so his name is Ted or was 10
bingo mm-hmm canyons horseshoe he's a
chef he's got a casino downtown but he
was like a Texas like gangsta yeah yeah
I already like the story
so Ted who's the son of this gangster
right because Benny was a gangster right
well he wasn't really he was like an
unofficial gangster he was just a yeah
yeah an official gangster like he wasn't
a part of the mob you look like a cowboy
but you you just had gangster like
traits like very tough guy and all that
he's a poker player and he opened up a
casino to go son Ted he had his live-in
girlfriend and this girlfriend was
cheating on him with a contractor who
helped Ted build an underground vault in
the desert in his ranch to store his
seven million dollar silver fortune the
girlfriend and the lover
they killed Ted oh no and and dug up the
all the silver and but the they were
able to recuperate and all that stuff
but the way they killed in those [ __ ]
up they made they force him to ingest
lethal levels of heroin and then tied to
presidents annex and then suffocated to
call it a suicide
yeah like an overdose overdose oh like
Dateline when they didn't even discover
that it was because he had a problem
with drugs so initially cops her like uh
overdose but then that's when like the
family stories and stuff they started
investigating and then they they saw
marks on his like just random marks all
over his body but particularly around
her mouth and they were and then they
looked under his eyelid and there were
like signs that he was suffocating
I probably like pop blood vessels [ __ ]
strangling is a different one right
suffocate think with the pillow like was
something some kind of cloth over their
feet you know when one same our son is
this recent I told you 1998 so the
tempur-pedic pillow wasn't invented yet
I think it was out in 98 it was
commercials I feel like we should go he
was like that's the weapon of choice
right all he's done oh now this brings
us to present time awareness a manager
of that property
his name is Richard he's 56 years old
okay he him and two other men were found
or like they were seen on surveillance
footage digging up the ranch trying to
look for this silver is it private
property that's he was a manager of that
property oh yeah did he find it not that
I know of but he did get arrested okay
was he booked on a burglary conspiracy
of conspiracy and destruction of
property so no one knows where the
silver is well that's the thing it's
believed that most of it was already
recovered yeah but there's this like
rumor but there's still some still some
left this Ted guy apparently like to
bury his valuables value you like to
bear it all oh man he looks like he's on
meth it's Matthew
you've got a that's exactly what it is
dude what the [ __ ] is going on right now
dude why they always with crazy [ __ ]
though rich guys it was one of the
casinos because they're hot right rich
guys always with like hot crazy [ __ ]
you know what I mean like why can't like
I don't know there's no I think hot
crazy is Will Ferrel crazy [ __ ] I
think are aiming for rich guys too yeah
they make themselves available they're
the ones like chasing them maybe that's
probably true I wouldn't put it past but
can I see like the gangster that you
were talking about like can you Benny
Binion yeah you look like a nice old man
no you were talking about like he was
like a low-key gangster like I want to
see like a facial expression of like a
low-key gangster in your opinion that's
it okay that's that's what it is I got
it I like those chairs thought - yeah
you let your hand let me get that's good
I like it I believe that because you
can't tell that he was a gangster yeah
[Laughter]
that's the story here well that's very
interesting very casino yeah it has like
poker games there
yeah Binion's Horseshoe is it's in
downtown Vegas we went inside there
before how do you I think we played
craps there actually are you good at
poker and crabs like that um I play I
don't know if I'm good I'm good I get so
nervous to gamble because am I gonna
want to spend oh the whole point in that
case I'm good no I'm like that every day
wait you do you like to gamble yeah do
you like to gamble uh it's okay only
with my friends only one everyone else
Gamble's I'll jump in by myself
i gamble to achieve that feeling of
anxiety I do but you want more of it
well I think aren't the what triggers
the anxiety it takes more I think that's
what it is for you any when I get
anxious I feel alive and I feel good I
feel happy and I feel good kind of
anxious yeah well don't you like that
[ __ ] you like the jump off of a [ __ ]
yeah yeah but not like a daily like
anxiety anxiousness
girl I could gamble every day really
yeah it makes me feel like it's like a
cup of coffee I get up in the morning
and I gamble and then I start my day a
gentleman at all dude but it goes with
the to like adrenaline is anxiety
causing everyone yeah it's like safe
anxiety because there's no real threat
right you just hoping that you win yeah
just relax
relaxing make you feel dead it makes me
feel dead it depends on the doha ye I'll
be like hey you're relaxing too much I
don't want you to feel sad get off even
when I'm in Hawaii I'm still like
swimming around and like climbing
shooting right in the front line yeah
wait you guys go to Hawaii when you
going away all the time tomorrow
I don't here's your wedding yeah where
did you guys get married they're cute
yeah just because I've been divorced
doesn't mean I don't believe in love and
still think it's a real thing yeah I'm
not bitter about it at all like cool I
want everyone do you still have hope in
love actually I really do that's a bad
experience I did don't let anything let
you down no it shouldn't me be patient
you know it will come you know take the
time to get to know someone I look for
younger dudes too I tried that actually
I dated an asian girl
what
listen there's a general area shoe for
right so you know when you have you know
what you have a target there's the red
center those rings around it you went
like this and you went this I didn't
like younger guys and I didn't I did
find out I didn't you know like when
you're looking for a vehicle it's either
a unicycle or something that's like you
know when I go you know there commit all
the way or I don't yes or no there's no
in-between
you know how are you with the 18 year
old I was 27 damn bro you were dating a
baby technically was only nine years
versus 33 a nine year this is the 18
because it feels like years who cares
hey I wasn't searching for it he split
into my dams I wasn't like I was on a
nap boy I want to date an 18 year old I
didn't think about it I didn't want just
like you're like damn he's fine you're
like oh you're 18 all right I'll work
with that I mean he lied about his age
so I was like oh that's a different
story
yeah you heard that he was I ate in your
life no I don't get turned off it I like
older guys obviously you just feel like
such a pain you're like older guys you
like people on the brink of death I know
but like I drove - yeah that's my mommy
right you being mommy you want to be you
want to be controlled and I knew his mom
my mom is his mom's actually best
friends with one of my best friends
which was really weird
super weird yeah that was really I was
like okay I feel really uncomfortable
now do it for him as an 18 year old to
bag a 27 year old but you must have felt
like he was on top of the world yeah his
graduation was interesting high school
graduation
not to that now to the main event to the
dinner afterwards because I have
self-respect though I wouldn't have
showed up at either you're supportive
you are an awesome person did he like
ask you to get him beer and [ __ ] no but
I actually did go out and date with him
and his friends the double date
what are you doing [ __ ] I died because I
was just I was going through a divorce
no one makes good decisions when you're
doing that you know what I mean like
that was no all of them had fake IDs and
I was like oh my gosh I'm the only one
that is of age I don't want to be
responsible some [ __ ] goes down like
this was it was like okay I got about
what was it like when he was going
through his SATs and [ __ ] I mean I don't
even know I was just like this is so not
my scene like what my extreme person you
do like anxiety did the biggest gambler
of all you're all [ __ ] ended I think
we have 10 different forms of anxiety
inducing lifestyles do your [ __ ]
gangsters [ __ ] you had the best podcast
on earth
[Music]
you
[Music]